really is the dick-pic dick-pic I don't
know if you guys have been on Twitter
lately I mean there's been some real
heavy things going on in the world
absolutely there's something that I came
across an article on cosmic book news of
a thread of Grace Randolph from beyond
the trailer and Kathy Ann director
birds-of-prey going back and forth
getting into a debate which of course
ignited a lot of commentators some
people attacking and some people
defending on both sides of this argument
basically the story is about Kathy Anne
is saying Grace Randolph falsely
reported on something and painted a lot
of things in bad light so there's all
these arguments about proper journalism
grace defending herself on her sources
and we're gonna show you guys all the
screenshots we can gather when this
started here's what I want to say
there's two things I want to address
right up front first thing is because of
the felt like with our opening line we
make fun of like almost every youtuber
that we think of but it's never it's
rarely rarely rarely do we have an
actual agenda or mean it in a mean
spirited way no beef right yeah it's
like no beef the big thing was when we
did our end game sketch you know we
there were jokes about like grace
Randolph was gonna beat us to this she
was born February 5th 1987 has written
several comic books but like hell we let
people know how much we follow are in
Grace Randolph commented on her video
like saying job well done boys and we
were like yay you know we make our jokes
but we need if you guys watch as long
enough you'll see we make fun of like
almost anyone and it's never in a mean
way yeah it's always in good fun if we
were going back and forth with Kathy Ann
on Twitter and grace reported on that
it's fair exactly I don't want this at
all to be taken out of context as if
we're trying to expose or trying to get
drama or beef started or being like
what's up grace Randolph although I
would be fascinated to see her video I
would like an actual video what is this
is movie news alright and movie news I
don't think needs to be taken as
seriously or cause so much
outrage as a lot of people tend to react
to movie news because it's just fine
it's just [ __ ] movie news is
entertainment fiction right and I know
that like in any fan base you often get
people who talk [ __ ] get passionate I
get it with us you know it's fun to
debate about but if you're actually
losing your cool you should stop for a
Miss now to shift gears for just a tiny
tiny little bit a lot of people are
saying today like they're not going to
be doing videos on YouTube because of
what's going on in the world with the
protests and such I understand that and
if you follow me on Instagram and
Twitter you'll see that I am very much
passionate about what is going on in the
world right now
yesterday I actually did go to the the
protest held officially by black lives
matter in Long Beach California and for
the time I was there it was a very
peaceful protest even at one point there
was an individual singular individual
who broke a windshield to a car and a
bunch of people gathered around the car
putting their hands up saying like
making sure like no you gotta stop that
no we could do this around like 5:20
p.m. there was confusing alerts going
off curfews at 6:00 curfews at 8:00
curfews at 6000 most of us got like
three different ones were like what
times the curfew but this is kind of
strange we were heading back to our car
already the thing that happened was for
the most part it was a very beautiful
very peaceful protest I don't
necessarily want to go out there and
make a video that is solely about this
but I did feel like I have to at least
say something I couldn't stay completely
silent at the end of the day yeah I mean
we even when we do our live streams the
thing we always say before we do a live
stream on the weekend is these guys have
had a rough week most likely let's just
give them a sense of escapism we're
talking about movies primarily you know
it should always be fun when you're talk
exactly is to some extent but I can't
deny this is what's mainly on my mind
and like I said you follow me on social
media you'll see what I wanted to just
use this time to say was we're not your
sources for it however I would heavily
encourage you to get educated really be
educated I did start to feel that real
anger after being at the Long Beach
because you'll see a lot of celebrities
who will retweet these like very
beautiful peaceful moments by the
thousands of people that are there and
that's the majority of the time of the
actual protest of wanting to do
something right and fighting for the
right things in a peaceful manner
good news we'll just take like Oh
looting let's list report that what's
happening right now is very important I
think what's great about what's
happening is that it's becoming a
worldwide event you know seeing people
in London Germany first it was like just
going all around America but then seen
other countries get involved in the
black lives matter movement is very
important and I also want to say that if
you're out in a city where there are
protests going on
do whatever you can to be safe because
as we've seen and you guys already know
she can get out of hand I would also say
don't just only watch the news matter of
fact on social media you can find actual
unedited footage that is not going on
the news of either peaceful protest or
the enduring police brutality that is
going on during these protests or you're
seeing people who are literally
surrendering not doing anything or just
being a flat-out assaulted flat-out
abuse and some very disturbing ways it's
important that yes you got to find your
time for escapism I encourage that you
got to find your time to get your mind
off of things I encourage you to be
educated on this matter
the main victim who where this all over
the protest really stemmed from is from
George Floyd and it was a terrible
terrible thing that happened to him
there are so many people people of color
who are abused or killed and by just
institutionalized racism it's baked into
our culture in a lot of ways even if he
can't see it and a lot of times it it is
not something that's being reported on
it's not something that's being really
publicized so what's happening right now
is important so I just want to take some
time out to say get encouraged
go to black lives matter calm and then
relief filmed yeah go go to the help fun
section to go donate this is important
do what you can to be educated on it
listen to people of color elevate their
voices and this is everybody's problem
whether you like it or not yeah we're
all stuck on this rock together now
let's talk about something that's
actually serious Kathy and that's the
serious stuff
alright guys so here's where this really
started like I said this is honestly
just thought this was very entertaining
it that's why I wanted to talk about it
it's not every day you get news is juicy
this actually started with her homeboy
David Ayer and who has really been
talking a little bit more in-depth
actually about how different his
original a Orkut was intended to be for
Suicide Squad right he's been responding
to a lot of people and then he put out
one tweet that said this was just one of
many where he said this was reshot
because the tone was too dark my first
act was a normally constructed film to
clients I loved that I took my
inspiration from Nolan there were real
scenes with incredible acts I love you
guys Harley was complex this is f marvel
I love that I love how sometimes I use
the F word and then Kathy Ann said I'm
so sorry this happened to you David I
know the pain which made a lot of people
started questioning you know like wait a
minute what we heard about birds of prey
reshoots but the movie was received well
I thought this was the film you want her
to make from that's what every director
says what every director says until
they're allowed to speak the truth and
then Grace Randolph who I remember being
one of the main people to have reported
on this and I believe that when she
reported on the reshoots and then some
things that studios were not happy about
I remember that time now no think about
it a lot of people were reporting on her
reports because the thing with Grace
Randolph a lot of times she gets two
scoops on things sometimes she's wrong
sometimes she's right I want to make
that clear right all right there are
plenty of times where I have found grace
randolph to be correct like everyone
else in her field in our field sometimes
you're wrong okay times there's a margin
of error because like we will tum times
talk about leaks and stuff the thing
that we like to do though is we always
make a disclaimer even if it really
falls under the radar we usually make a
disclaimer this might not be real it
this is real if this is to be believed
we say that but we always roll with the
foot the story and treat it as if it's
more fun cuz like I said it's just
moving it and what we're about to unveil
it will lead to a wide variety of
opinions probably from us from you guys
this is in no way I'm not trying to do
an attack video okay not what it is I
told you guys massive reshoots largely
to take out dick pics storyline and add
more action VHS the hell ski I'm
surprised Kathy Ann would jump on this
bandwagon though birds of prey variables
well-received by critics and has a very
strong fan base that the he Myint ly
defense film as is DC EU now Kathy Ann
did not text O'Connor I said excuse me
you have no idea what you're talking
about
it's fascinating you would deem to try
when you weren't part of the process
whatsoever that's the thing when you get
into Twitter Wars I have a way of
interpreting the voices so clearly Kathy
Ann is not happy with Grace Randolph
reporting on this or having said that so
Grace Randolph replied no reporter is
ever part of the process I love how
grace runoff is retweeting this to
different jobs every should we do that
does that make your tweets see more or
maybe just cloud cheese everything I
reported is common knowledge with many
insiders I brought it to the public one
thing I'll say too and a little minor
defense for grace here when she says
everyone always says inside source every
leak you've ever heard it says it's a
source is the most vague term I have
found sometimes our inside sources
whomever they may be can be correct all
right there's gets it gonna happen and
there are I'm sure their industries are
100% legit and some of them are also
just like janitors who heard something
wrong he said I gave your film a good
review and I said here you have a strong
fan base so logically there should be no
problem here unless there's
misinformation let's just misinformation
that was probably a problem right and I
thank you for the support but let's set
the record straight now and when you say
that word but that negates everything
that came before I'm just saying with
her butt pics he said there were never
dick pics you peddling a pedophilia
rumor is not journalism peddling any
gossip is not journalism I know I was
one she has a point now the sad part
about movie news yes a lot of it's gone
most of what we gossip that you hope
will be proven true sir outlet is
reliable and now more so than ever
because everything is delayed who so
many people are reporting on God's the
gossip is what drives the traffic now
yeah this is a movie news thing I'm
talking about here there's not a solely
Grace Randolph thing we'll talk about
the gossip a lot of people do because
it's one of the few places in which it's
fun to muse about that it's not fun in
real world it's just always important to
make a disclaimer that this might not be
true yeah all right it's always
important to say that this is a rumor
especially if you cannot credit or cite
your source exactly and she said
multiple reporters confirm that story
after I reported it and said it was
great and she'd be kept in the film and
did it like it take it out and dick pics
arm pedophilia Plus as a former
journalist you should realize the optics
are not pretending you have a suddenly
better Yan Kai I mean is she doing that
I don't feel like I feel like that's a
leap I feel like at best she is going
yeah the studio also kind of
strong-armed my vision maybe is kind of
what I'm getting out of that I'm not
necessarily getting yam cut I mean it is
interesting because and there's more
here it just stops being interesting
after this what's interesting about this
particular thing is that birds of prey
while there's a lot of people who
especially I'd like the YouTube
reviewers who really didn't like it you
know and we were one of like very few
people I actually didn't see crais's
review on this movie I believe that she
gave it a positive review we were like
two dudes who actually loved it see you
flicks I'm sorry for Kathy Ann having to
go through that I know this is what most
directors who are involved with a big
studio film go through this is usually a
part of the process especially if they
haven't done a huge tree of
yeah it's part of it so I'm not really
like championing for like a Cathy Yan
cut cuz I don't really know what's not
in that movie and I already loved what
we got unless she comes out next week
and is like the whole film was different
yeah you know then okay we'll talk about
that Cathy Ann responded saying that is
not true this is not true there has
never been any discussion around the
size of Romans dick I can't believe I
even have to write that the original
script called for an image of Roman as
Michelangelo's David you know art if
there's a dick pic then the Louvre is
full of them Kathy ed is very she's
talking down talking if it sounds like
she Kathy Ann has probably had a lot of
resentment towards her in this process
because what you're about to see next he
tweeted this thing out meanwhile
articles like the one below are written
off of your scoops congratulations on
being the scum of journalism now a lot
of people did not take kindly to that
first of all she was already talking
down and then she did name-calling which
and a lot of time when you start going
into that territory people immediately
try to discount your whole argument and
being like okay now I'm on Grace's side
because your name called you know so
this article that she put out was Margot
Robbie birds of prey has pedophilia
elements and this comes from the website
cosmic book not news funny enough this
is where I found the original the
article that led me to do all this
Twitter threat and she said that's not
my story how can I control the reporters
don't quote me accurately I never said
pedophilia in my reporting ever and
Kathy your recent tweets just proved my
story correct which you've clearly never
bothered to see and name-calling isn't a
good look for anyone now there is
footage a user put out
this is not the whole video for all I
know there could be a more of a further
elaboration here a lot people
referencing this point that grace
brought up in a video and nine seconds
long here it is having an underage girl
swallow something that has pictures of
adult private parts on it seems
questionable at best next so she didn't
say the words pedophilia but you know
the question is what makes a
questionable a situation of that the
article the headline it really does use
that word
it's an alley-oop it's like she
insinuates the the idea and then the
article just goes full-on is there yes
you know let's break some of this down
okay because there was some other random
thread that occurred where she where
grace was saying the storyline was that
you could use Romans dick on the statue
in the picture in the diamond he was a
said it looks small so that's why he was
so fixated on getting it back a picture
of statues dick especially in this
context is a dick pic well if it's just
of the dick yes daniel richtman who's
Daniel RPK who has reported on a lot of
things and leaks that have been true
before it said she's talking about the
dick pics in Rome and blast be Roman
black mass being explicitly gay this was
a receipt that grace randolph retweeted
right Daniel RPK Gabby Anne and with the
book don't bring me in this also there
were never any dick pics I got used to
say that but it was a naked statue and
we the mortal Romans character being a
valuable art collector and well very
well done nothing Pete about it like you
tried to claim your tweet literally says
dick pics Daniel welcome to the party no
I don't know where this whole swallowing
photo of it is coming from anything in
this thread that was like her clarifying
where that came from maybe it was
something here about like inside sources
in terms of her argument with Daniel RPK
he is saying she's talking about the
dick
ya know to like talk about the statue
and then just say dick pics it's like
yes now this is a technicality semantics
argument this is a game of like the
worst kind of telephone without any kind
of vocal intonation or anything to go
along with any of these words it is a
bit of a word salad sandwich so long
gathering this information and proper
formations I've been trying to
communicate I know I mean I'm fascinated
by the what's gonna happen to this
because I think there are points being
made on both sides that are fair enough
I mean yeah grace is doing what's well
within her right as a reporter to take
scoops and yeah in movie news as much as
it's problematic a big part of what
thrusts movie news is possibility is
rumors is prospect I'm feeling like this
situation is blowing really out of
proportion
I mean yeah if you go back and you look
at the movie and according to Kathy yen
they basically went in they said okay
the statue thing isn't really that funny
it's not really contributing to the
movie we'll add a few lines of dialogue
to replace what's on the thing in the
diamond with something else and so I'm
confused as to what the truth is
obviously because I'm sitting here going
is this is small of a details Kathy Ann
is making it out to be or is this is
huge of a detail in like a plot overhaul
as Grace is making it out to be and I
think it's gonna be a while before we
have an idea of the truth of that yeah
that's the weird thing about this
argument yeah this is like wait I think
I'm like looking at her for her first
tweet in response to a Kathy Ann first
said to David Ayer she said I told you
guys
massive reshoots largely to take out
dick pic storyline and add more action
via Chad's
the house key the action part seems
large I mean the act but the thing is is
like I can't deny that when you when you
say that when you put that as your first
sentence in the tweet yeah it makes it
sound like there's this big word like
this dick we need to rewrite this take
the dicks I'll just put action I don't
know that's what this is about
like it does can read like that it does
a hundred percent that's the there's two
things she's talking about in that
sentence
it's see it sounds like we need to take
the dick pics out and put more action
whereas Kathy Ann is saying no that's
that is like that was really a little
thing about a statue oh you know yeah
and it's like I get how this boiled out
of this CNY I guess I'm inclined to kind
of believe what Kathy Anne's saying here
because I can also see how easily if the
game of telephone could have worked here
because there is a nude image involved
and so now you can just kind of reframe
that and look at it from multiple angles
and put it out to people from multiple
angles I mean I do feel like grace
believes what she believed that do I
don't know I mean maybe it could be and
maybe people realize that was not a
great decision and they're embarrassed
by it but I don't know why it would lead
to this level of conflict if that was
really the case this is why I don't have
like a super strong opinion on this to
like attacker defense and what cuz I'm
like it's a movie reshot beat because of
this other thing is Kathy hands meeting
it's not like it's not reshot because of
this and that little tidbit was blown
out of proportion
turning to dick pics turn into Cassandra
Cain swallowing photos you know then
turns into a pedophilia discussion which
turns into trying to be too edgy to okay
you know I'm not sure it's like I don't
have all of Grace's full video here to
see if she says anything about like if
is this true if this is this to be
believed cuz sometimes she can just
state things as if this is the actual
thing and a lot of times if something
comes out and she happens to be right
like the way she started out with this
with this tweet of like told you guys
you know like that told you guys think I
was right yeah especially if you're in
the business of breaking scoops I think
it yeah trying to always boost your
credibility yeah yeah exactly and that's
the thing is is looking at what's
happening here it almost feels like the
conflict is more of an inch
personal one than a conflict over what's
actually in the movie because it seems
like if you boiled down what they're
talking about the core elements are kind
of agreeable there's a situation that
got changed involving a nude visit of
Romans Iona's yeah so like part of me
almost feels like the actual whether or
not it's weird it's like I'm trying to
zero in on the core of the conflict and
I'm not entirely sure what it actually
is
other than journalism at the end of the
day I feel like anytime you rest upon
industry insiders you're in a dubious
position because that's a 50/50
crapshoot well grace randolph has a lot
of clout at the end of the day she does
whatever opinions you have of her she
does have a lot of clout to the point
that if she says something there's gonna
be people who run with what she said oh
yeah as if this is the latest breaking
thing that's just the way it goes it's
not her fault if someone runs with her
story and uses different vocabulary and
then changes up a lot of the context of
what she was talking about that is true
at the same time there is a sense of
accountability on the form of journalism
though if you're in this position and
you you're aware of hey when I break
something people will run with it you
got to be better at articulating or
knowing where your facts are coming from
like I said there's a lot of time she is
right and a lot of time though with
situations like this I imagine can
really upset a director because like I
get where Kathy Ann's coming from at the
same time because that information led
to a lot of bad press and which put her
on the receiving end of getting a lot of
crap oh yeah and then it's it's oh yeah
I can imagine being in a position like
where did this start [ __ ] well yeah
and also just because as the director I
feel like that is one of the roles in
filmmaking where you can easily be
blamed for all kinds of things that
weren't necessarily your fault or or you
can be overlooked for things that were
you're doing it's got to be weird to be
a director especially yeah when you have
people shouting at you before your
movies even come out the person I would
be really fascinated to hear from hon
this is Margot Robbie too because she
had a big part in choosing Kathy Anne
and in guiding the vision of
I got imagine this sucks for the both of
them too to have a dick related
controversy slapped on to their movie
for what the movie is for the amount of
controversy that gender equality and
feminism caused people right now to have
it just seems so regressive and so
utterly frustrating to have a literally
giant dick controversy surrounding this
movie right now and especially for Kathy
Ann as a director getting in that
position getting to break some ground
and make a statement I don't begrudge
her the ire of inif I do sort of wish
she had maybe pulled back a little on
some of the attack mode and I think what
grace is also trying to to say is that
with her inside sources usually that's
not communicated I don't feel like the
way how when she reports at least the
way it's its phrase and a lot of her
reporting is that this is not a gossip
this is a fact but the fact that she
can't say who her sources are she can't
cite them so it turned makes it a gossip
report you know if you can't cite a
source like you can't cling to the
legitimacy with any level of solidity
okay but does that make it a gossip
report even if like if grace was really
under the impression this was a fact you
know yeah I guess it's technically to me
it still is I mean if you're convinced I
don't know it depends on who her sources
she must trust her source so in that
sense sure but if you're giving it again
I think there's a certain amount
especially in the day and age where
people don't read full articles or
bother to look at who wrote them I think
that it's the same once it gets to the
people either way exactly it's gossip
for us until it's proven true or false
well there's no real conclusion no now
I'm sitting here wondering because
that's the thing is is David Ayer with
Suicide Squad at first was a big team
player about it and now he's been able
to open up and so as much as I like
birds of prey way more than that
theatrical cut I also wouldn't be
surprised if Kathy Ann didn't have the
most fluid experience making that movie
and interacting with the studio what's
funny too is before all this David
airing
and grace randolph were going back and
forth but it was a very positive and
respectful it's the Joker didn't swallow
a hard drive full of dick pics yeah that
wasn't that wasn't what they cut out of
suicides what does that be fun to share
with you guys you got a hold there
journalism and movie news more
accountable yeah yeah political news
whatever you know that's whatever what I
believe everyone believes but movie news
that's the integrity what do you think
guys we're to do a video so silly it's
so opinionated and such a feud between
like a it seems like more of a one-sided
feud because Kathy Anne's really angry
yeah and grace Ralph was just trying to
defend herself in credibility and then
for us to be like this is funny this is
interesting I don't really have a solid
conclusion they both have some kind of a
point yeah we'll never know the truth
probably but they both just want to drop
this I mean there are people on both
sides
you go through Twitter you'll see that
there's gonna be before very much on
Kathy Ann side there are people very
much on grace ran outside and I'm more
on the side of grace
you know maybe start citing who your
sources are I feel like that could hurt
your source yeah might hurt your source
but I feel like if your source was
someone who was like oh damn [ __ ] get
why you believed you know make the world
of difference in this argument yeah yeah
and so it's an odd lead tricky situation
because now we're seeing that yet
journalism obviously has a direct effect
on film sometimes but also you know a
lot of us especially in the movies fear
are put in this position where the
biggest breaking stories are the ones
with dubious credibility exactly because
that's the whole point is like oh it's
breaking news well what's your take on
this what do you think is this a big
deal was it fun is a very long video are
you self-conscious that it wasn't a
bigger deal subscribe click the
notification bell to you guys